there are fears that a serial killer is
on the loose in Tampa Florida police are
warning people not to walk alone at
night in the Seminole Heights
neighborhood that's after a third person
in ten days was shot to death on
Thursday night and as men weld the work
as reports while the victims did not
appear to know one another
police seems certain that their murders
are all connected frightened residents
did what they could to reclaim the
streets of Seminole Heights Friday night
a day after 20 year-old Anthony Noboa
was found shot to death on a sidewalk
the autistic man had just gotten off the
wrong bus home from work when he was
shot his family knew something was wrong
when he didn't come home this is the
most awful feeling that you can feel
that you know that your child is dead
and you had these people coming to let
you know to confirm him it's very
devastating police heard the shots that
killed a boa there were extra patrols in
the area after two other murders in ten
days
no boa was shot just about a hundred
yards away from where Benjamin Mitchell
was killed on October 9th on October
13th
Monica hafez body was found in a vacant
lot less than a mile away she was shot
and killed two days earlier now we have
someone who was terrorizing a
neighborhood
Tampa police say they have no leads and
can't determine a motive on Friday they
released surveillance video of a person
walking in the area when the first
murder happened the only thing they
seemed certain of is that the murders
are not a coincidence through the
proximity and the time frame you know
they are related there's no doubt in our
mind about that police are hoping the
public can help something Anthony knew
Boas stepmother says needs to happen I
just hope that someone in the community
can speak out do not be afraid because
like my husband said it could be your
daughter your grandson your son your
wife your husband whoever may be in your
family you don't know when is gonna be
your turn to speak up just because for
CBS this morning Saturday Manuel
Bojorquez